let us face without panic the reality of our times
the fact that atom bombs may someday be dropped
on our cities and let us prepare for survival
by understanding the weapon that threatens us
an atom bomb destroys or injures in three ways by
blast heat and radioactivity the blast of an atom
bomb is its most important destructive agent in
Japan whole buildings were flattened by its force
however many buildings of sturdy construction even
though close to the explosion remained standing
the principal dangers of blasts are flying glass
and debris the fires it may start and the danger
of being crushed in collapsing buildings the atom
bomb destroys by heat people caught in the open
as far as two miles away suffered flesh burns yet
protection could have been easily achieved here a
bridge post and rail shielded the surface behind
it any solid material afforded similar protection
the third weapon of the bomb is radioactivity
thrown off at the instant of explosion
however the majority of people exposed to
radiation recovered completely including a
large percentage of those who suffered serious
radiation sickness today they lead normal lives
they bear children their children are normal
these then are the weapons of the atom bomb
that we must protect against blast heat and
radioactivity our cities are prime targets
for atomic attack but mass evacuation would
be disastrous an enemy would like nothing
better than to have us leave our cities empty
and unproductive if an emergency should come
our factories will be battle stations
production must go on if we are to win
our officers and homes will also
be posted duty not to be deserted
with the knowledge of the first atomic explosions
to guide us our chances for survival will be far
better than those of the people of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki if we act on our knowledge and
are prepared the first job is to look over
your own home for shelter possibilities if
you live in a private home that is well built
the cellar is the safest place to be the lower
you get the more barriers there are likely
to be against blast heat and radioactivity
select the basement wall nearest the probable
target area of your city if the house is blown
over it will most likely fall away from this
wall if you have a workbench or strong table
big enough to get under move it into your
shelter area near a wall or strong supporting
column if the time comes when you actually
have to take shelter lie under the table
if you live in a home that has no basement
choose a shelter area without windows on
the ground floor an interior hallway is
probably best in time of emergency the
shelter area should be cleared of mirrors
and other objects that might cause injury
if you lived in an apartment house
rules for taking shelter will be
posted in your building learn them also learn the
location of public shelters in areas
where you work or frequently visited
there are many things you can begin doing right
now fireproof housekeeping is one so clean up
that happy keep waste in covered containers
don't let trash pile up in the yard set aside
a small supply of canned goods they're safe
from radioactivity have a good flashlight on
hand electric lights may go out keep a first-aid
kit and learn how to stop bleeding make a habit
of keeping a bottle of fresh water handy a
radio will be important for receiving vital
instructions finally prepare the shelter area
and collect all necessary shelter equipment
in case of an actual raid or test drill the alert
will be a warbling siren blast lasting freedom
once you hear this act fast
pull down the shades or blinds
and close the drapes against
flying glass turn off the burners of
your gas or electric stove disconnect
any heating elements such as electric
irons hot plates or bathroom heaters
close all outside doors but leave them
unlocked turn off the gas or oil burners
taking shelter maybe a race against time
even when you have some advance warning
but possibly there may be no time
an attack could come without warning
the sky would suddenly light up if the doorway
is right at hand use it if the nearest shelter
is more than a couple of steps away fall
to the ground immediately flying glass
and debris or immediate danger so stay where
you are until you're sure it's safe to move
if you are at home when a surprise attack occurs
all beneath the table if it is very nearer or
drop to the floor with your back to the window
the immediate danger is over in about a minute
unless the explosion occurred near the ground
or water in this case radioactive materials
are trapped in the particles of dirt or water
thrown up by the explosion when these particles
fall back to earth they may be dangerous so
get indoors immediately after a ground-level
explosion cover broken windows against radioactive
dust with blankets or cardboard civil-defense
radiological teams equipped with radiation
survey meters will check on contamination in
any bombed area stay undercover until you hear
officially that it is safe outside if you have
been exposed to radioactive dust wash the exposed
areas pay particular attention to your hair get
all the dirt from under your fingernails if the
people of Hiroshima and Nagasaki had known what
we know about civil defense thousands of lives
would have been saved yes the knowledge is ours
and preparation can mean survival for you so
act now someday your life may depend on it